and he's like six yeah and he's just
like with the middle finger to my face
shut up your ching ching chong and I'm
looking at him and I'm trying to hold in
my laugh but at the same time right my
Asian side wanted to grab his
and like spank him right but then I'm
like I'm in a government space like what
are the rules here
[Music]
so there's a Waffle House worker in
Alabama thank you for your service who
received a tip after a group of friends
all came together
um to eat at the Waffle House and so the
bill comes in at 74 and they leave one
thousand one hundred dollar tip whoa why
on purpose
on purpose what was this guy wearing is
it Mr Beast is it a meme is it like a
meme that they're doing for tick tock no
they do they do this I guess they do
this every year they have like a friends
giving group and every year they do like
they go somewhere and then they do like
a generous tip oh that's really cool
that's and they didn't have to put it on
YouTube oh that's tight so they put it
on YouTube and they monetize the [__]
okay that's good they made it back your
money back get your money back yes but
it's 1001 yeah they had ad break every
five seconds on the video
get your money back yeah
um but they sit wherever the host ends
up sitting them every year and then they
don't know the waitress or who same
restaurant no they do different places
that's really cool yeah Waffle House
people would need it yeah that's tight
you know if you're working at Waffle
House on the holidays you're gonna need
that tip especially on the holidays what
if they got like they grabbed their
group of friends they're like all right
we're gonna go to 12 Falls today and
we'll leave the tip today today's the
day we always do it and they get the
server and they're like the worst server
ever do they still leave the tip or
they're like ah let's postpone this
little tomorrow no you can't dude they
can't [__] leave a tip for the worst
server not about the service right it's
just about the act of giving right yeah
but if that guy is [__] giving them a
hard time what if what if they're like
the worst server you've ever had but
like so bad were you like oh you're
probably a bad person outside of here
yeah you never had bad servers to the
point where you want to get them fired
because you're like you shouldn't even
be working at this business what if he's
like hey I'm so sorry we don't have
Chinese food sir this is a Waffle House
you just sat down yeah
but you're like we're still gonna tip
it's a spirit of giving so you can I
would be like I'll just be like that's
fine I didn't come here for Chinese food
we don't have Kung Pao potatoes sir like
sorry sir
he's like what kind of ching chong are
you oh damn see that Vietnamese kind
that was not as bad as what Steve said I
think I would take that one here's the
bill General so
that's good General song
that's a good one it's a deep cut
General cells is white people food guys
come on don't take my generals still
good I need to go to a PF Chang's again
and give it another chance dude they're
fried rice really is it it's good
because sometimes it just tastes like
Panda Express on a nice plate you and uh
you and Nigel should go to a PF Chang's
together yeah and review it
you know what I randomly think about I
think about them going out there giving
this like server [__] 1100 tip
and then like the other server who's
working the same shift is looking over
like
[__] lucky ass [__] wait did
they split tip well that's what that's
what I was wondering do they make sure
that it's a place where all the tip goes
to that specific waiter because a lot of
places are gonna pull it it seems like
there's a theme here so last year around
Christmas time they went to a Cracker
Barrel
they tipped the waitress 575 after
paying a 24 Bill whoa wow how many group
of friends is this it's like five people
five people running for a 24 Bill damn
is it that cheap over there it's it's
this what dude five people for 24 bucks
what do they all just buy a biscuit yeah
group of ladies Real Housewives man
they're the ladies that go just get a
bunch of teas and coffees that's what it
is they all got coffee yeah it's a
low-cal high-tip meal biscuits yeah yeah
it's all their husband's money dude I
wish we had a Cracker Barrel here jeez
wait what did you say he said it's all
cans of money yeah that's I was just
saying what JoJo said oh Joe it was Joe
okay yeah he said what kind of ching
chong are you
chopiness guys money coming from a white
guy's mouth oh man
do you tip even when the service is bad
uh yeah just because but but not like
even when it's racist if it's terrible I
try to give them like 10 or below
wow you're really no you don't [__]
tell their manager hey this guy called
me ching ching chong oh if they didn't
which is like that's never happened to
me at a restaurant but I probably
wouldn't tip at all if it was like that
bad Joe tell them the story that why we
were saying this so many times
um I used to tutor down the street here
at the projects and um it was really
hard telling kids what to do because
they're so unruly right and then this
one boy
he just flipped me off in my face and he
said shut up you ching ching chong
[Laughter]
dumb right before he said it I'm like oh
I can't wait for the punchline
shut up you ching ching chong and he's
like six yeah and he's just like with
the middle finger to my face shut up you
ching ching chong and I'm looking at him
and I'm trying to hold in my laugh but
at the same time right my Asian side
wanted to grab his [__] and like
spank him right but then I'm like I'm in
a government space like what are the
rules here
that's good control yeah don't make a
training about you you tell his parents
like hey you know what no see it's a so
the the tutoring center none of these
guys they have parents that are
incarcerated or they're gone so they
live with their grandparents or a
guardian and then so uh the projects
here it's all it's all kids that live
under like like someone that's taking
care of them that can't that don't have
a job so they have broken families
basically and it's that [__] situations
huh that's why they're all crazy right
so so and then the the the tutoring
center they go there after school that's
like their babysitting
so some of the kids are cool and some of
the kids are just [__] some kids will
call you ching ching chong some kids
yeah what do you do when he does that so
I was like half laughing half what the
[__] right and then the two other ladies
clearly so I was like what do you do
when this [__] happens right then then
she goes yeah come over here she puts
them to the corner they talk yeah and
then she just does her like woman magic
all they say was like he's not even
Chinese he's Japanese
you got to be smarter than that yeah use
other materials
yeah shut up you Katakana
shut up you hot Tony Hanzo yeah that's
that's the stuff you want that's the
right one I'm real scared Musashi
that's it
it's all accurate see back then what I
would have done is reported this to the
next shark and then had next shark and
she's like you can't be offending Shang
Chi like this
student offends uh Joe and then it shows
a picture of him as just a little kid
it's a little kid with his middle finger
up a little Mexican kid shut up you
ching ching chong I like the idea that
some of the kids are cool and like some
other kid turns around and goes Marvin
go easy on Mr jitsu
he's cool he's a cool cat we're just
trying to learn I was waiting tables
there was this guy that came in he was
like this older white dude but he was
like he could have been homeless he was
like almost borderline borderline
he looked like he was clean you know but
also like kind of sketch he came he
comes in he orders like a drink and I
was like giving him change and as I was
giving him change he gave me another
like dollar and I was like I already
computed the change already so I was
like ah whatever just take this and he
goes he goes what the hell and I'm like
what he goes does does your boss know
that you're taking money from the
register not giving me correct change
you're giving me extra and I'm like yeah
it's fine it's okay don't worry about it
like it because when we were servers I
had to use we had to bring our own
change so it's our own change that we're
using so I was like yeah [__] it and I
was in a rush I needed this guy to go so
I just need to give him a [__] but he go
he looks at me and goes I thought Asians
would be good at math
[Laughter]
and I'm like I go yeah I'm not I'm not
that good at math man and then he he and
he just kept like giving me the [__]
stink eye as he was walking well why not
yeah yeah and I was like thank you sir
have a good one take care didn't we
subtract enough
and I remember thinking like that guy
was a dick and after I was thinking
about it I was like
man [__] that guy dude yeah [__] that
[__] that guy yeah but he's thinking you
gave me 32 cents extra exactly it's such
a weird time to get mad is that when you
go is that when you go out of your way
and you get a math test and you fail it
in front of them
I don't know what two plus two is so
wrong about the stereotype yeah Ricky
stereotypes about doing a math test in
front of him on a napkin the wrong way
it's very very good and then afterwards
I was like man that dude [__] that
was pretty funny
I don't know I don't even know if this
is really racist but one time I was
driving a Jeep on Hollywood Boulevard so
it was like there's no top I'm just like
you know driving and then the [__] uh
Hollywood tours bus thing stops next to
me and the [__] guy and the mic goes
all right everybody it's Bruno Mars
well like for some reason was just full
of black people and they were all going
oh [__]
and I was just like okay and then this
one dude stuck his head way out and so
he looked he pulled in the red light and
goes stop wait a minute
I was like [__] you got me man dude
that's rough when I was at New York Film
Academy like um [__] forever ago they
used to have those you know those Warner
Brothers tours and we were on we're
shooting on that lot and so like it
looks like and we're shooting like
student film [__] but like when the
tours are coming through all the
tourists are like holy [__] they're
shooting something and so I started um
like as the as soon as the tourists were
pulling up I started going okay
everybody we're rolling I'm like
Spider-Man three take one 417 action and
then all the [__] all the reaches
grabbing the [__] camera holy [__]
over here
that's how the [__] prank started
that's a really good prank
that's crazy that's your cute kid what
no add to it add to it say something hit
the button your ching ching chong
[__] oh [__] it's Bruno
[Music]
foreign